salut les chats se Trésor ont toujours
fasciné les gens les histoires de
pirates des trésors cachés sa captive
l'imagination de plein de plein de
personnes et sur toutes les générations
que ce soit les enfants ou les adultes
depuis des siècles et des siècles au
point d'en faire des livres des films et
aussi des personnages cultes qui
remplissent encore les salles
aujourd'hui si de nos jours il y a
beaucoup de trésors qui sont en réalité
des chasses trésor créé par des maisons
d'édition il y en a eu aussi des vrais
comme le trésor des Templiers au château
de griseur ou encore Olivier Levasseur
qu'on appelle la buse c'est un Pirat du
18e siècle dont la légende raconte
qu'elle alors qu'il était sur les
chapeaux donc quand vous allez la corde
au cou il y aurait jeté d'un assistance
à un cryptogramme et il aurait crié en
même temps mon trésor à qui sera le
prendre de la Hainer une chasse au
trésor qui dure depuis trois siècles
c'est assez long et bien sûr pour ceux
qui me suivent sur ma chaîne il y a eu
la célèbre Chouette d'Or je sais même
pas pourquoi je parle au passé à la 30
ans cette année la chute d'or une chasse
au trésor qui a été créée par Max
Valentin et qui dure depuis presque 30
ans donc et qui continue de passionner
beaucoup beaucoup de sseurs on les
appelle les shooter si ça vous dit elle
a toujours pas été trouvé et ils en ont
fait l'objet de mon premier documentaire
je vous le mets en lien dans la
description si vous voulez découvrir
cette histoire de dingue ceci étant dit
on part maintenant à la découverte des
plus grandes chasses au trésor dont une
qui vient de démarrer et à laquelle vous
pouvez participer si vous sentez l'âme
d'un explorateur regardez ça c'est très
intéressant
[Musique]
je commence par cette histoire parce que
franchement ça pourrait être un Indiana
Jones en 2010 Forrest fine un
millionnaire et collectionneur d'art
décide de lancer la plus grande chasse
au trésor de l'histoire des États-Unis
je dirais tout à l'heure pour quelle
raison il a décidé de la Lancer vous
allez voir c'est assez inattendu tous
les ingrédients pour faire un bon film
sont réunis il y a un coffre qui est
rempli de pierre précieuse il y a de
l'or des objets précolombiens le tout
pour une valeur de un million de dollars
un million c'est énorme c'est dans son
livre le frisson de la quête qu'il donne
des indices pour accéder au Trésor et
tous les éléments se trouvent dans un
poème de 24 vers la seule chose qui me
dit clairement et que le coffre se
trouve à 1500 mètres d'altitude au cœur
de la chaîne des montagnes Rocheuses
alors comment vous dire que le montagne
rocheuse traverse tout le continent
nord-américain entre le Nouveau Mexique
et l'Alaska sur une petite moyenne de
aller à la louche 5700 km ouais minimum
voilà voilà bah c'est sûr ça laisse de
quoi explorer au final je vous avais dit
que c'était dinganing Diana Jones tu
peux y consacrer une vie durant 10 ans
l'Amérique c'est passionné pour cette
chasse si bien que forrestenn a
comptabilisé pas moins de 350
000 personnes en quête de son trésor
pour mettre la main sur le magot le
problème conséquent et pas des moindres
c'est que l'accès à certaines zones sont
réputées très dangereuse et même si ça
effrayait pas forcément les chercheurs
d'or 4 personnes ils ont quand même
laissé leur vie dans cette quête au
trésor c'était tellement inacceptable
pour la police du Nouveau-Mexique qu'ils
ont même réclamé à forrestenn de mettre
fin à la chasse d'autant plus que
beaucoup pensaient qu'il s'agissait en
réalité d'une supercherie et qui avait
aucun trésor qui existait qui avait été
caché et c'est finalement au mois de
juin 2020 que le millionnaire a annoncé
que le trésor avait été trouvé par un
ancien journaliste étudiant en médecine
il va expliquer que plusieurs personnes
en suivant les indices du poème c'était
trouver à seulement 60 mètres du coffre
sans jamais mettre la main dessus alors
qu'ils étaient juste à côté des imaginez
le seum se sentent mètre je veux dire
c'est rien c'est un truc avec les années
l'or qui s'y trouvait a pris de la
valeur la valeur finale du Trésor qui a
été qui a été retrouvé en 2020 et estimé
à plus de deux millions de dollars ça
quasiment doublé et la raison pour
laquelle il a décidé de lancer ce défi
c'est parce qu'il venait d'échapper un
cancer durant et il était riche il a
voulu donner une raison aux gens de
bouger de leur canapé ça ce sont ces
mots tel qu'ils a prononcé alors c'est
sûr que 1 million de dollars ça motive
quand même à sortir de chez soi à se
lever du canapé si on a la piste sur
laquelle elle est et qu'on galère pas à
60 mètres du Trésor
est-ce que ça vous dirait de trouver un
trésor allez on va dire d'une petite
valeur de 100.000 euros ça fait plaisir
bon alors ce sont pas des paroles en
l'air parce que c'est une chasse au
trésor qui vient d'être lancée il s'agit
de l'élixir d'or c'est une chasse au
trésor mondiale donc elle a été traduite
en 7 langues et vous avez même pas
besoin de vous déplacer parce que les
énigmes elles peuvent être solutionnées
depuis chez vous dans votre canapé ou
devant votre bureau et vous déplacerez
que pour creuser pour la finalité à la
clé c'est une cave à vin d'une valeur de
100.000 euros et c'est d'ailleurs
sûrement l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles ce jeu est interdit aux
mineurs je vous parle de cette chasse
parce que elle est active actuellement
vous pouvez la faire la chasse elle
commence par le testament fictif du
conte de Saint-Germain c'est un
aventurien d'alchimiste un polyglotte un
espion et un personnage réputé immortel
du 18e siècle la preuve j'ai dit
immortelle ce compte a accumulé tout au
long de sa vie une immense cave à vin et
il décida un jour le jour de sa mort de
léguer cet héritage à une personne qui
en serait digne et qui serait capable de
résoudre les six énigmes qu'il a laissé
le principe du jeu il est super simple
il suffit de vous procurer un parchemin
je vais vous faire voir le mien qui
contient les six énigmes à résoudre une
fois résolu elles indiquent
l'emplacement très précis d'un coffre
qui est enterré quelque part en France
et qui contient un mystérieux élixir de
longue vie des bouts trouver le coffre
vous êtes déclaré le ou la gagnante du
jeu et le jeu du coup s'arrête le
gagnant est invité ensuite au château de
Vaux-le-Vicomte devant les médias des
personnalités des partenaires de
l'événement etc où elle se verra
remettre une immense collection de 4000
bouteilles de vin champagne spiritueux
français et tout ça évalué comme je vous
le disais à peu près 5000 euros mais
attention si vous n'aimez pas le vin
vous pouvez très bien choisir le produit
monétaire de la vente c'est vous qui
décidez ça alors si vous achetez la
boîte de jeu je vous dirai ou la trouver
tout à l'heure vous recevez cette boîte
dans laquelle oui j'ai ouvert oui j'ai
voulu regarder avant de vous faire la
vidéo dans lequel se trouve juste une
carte une immense carte un peu fou parce
que le principe d'avoir une grande carte
comme ça qu'on déroule déjà en vrai ça
met dans l'ambiance de la chasse au
trésor sur cette carte je trouve pas mal
de choses on trouve déjà le testament du
compte de Saint-Germain on trouve des
illustrations on trouve les six énigmes
qui sont sur la gauche alors ça le côté
illustration associée à des énigmes
écrite ça me rappelle un peu le mood de
la Chouette d'Or aussi hein si vous avez
un peu gratouillé la chouette dans votre
vie ça va vous parler et sur la partie
droite il y a les mentions légales la
dotation du Lot ça compte ça contient
quoi le Lot à date de mars de 2023 la
règle du jeu etc bon avant de vous
parler des autres chasses on va se
chauffer on va continuer sur l'élixir la
première énigme je découvre avec vous
c'est Prima Materia in vino veritas donc
là il y a un texte qu'on n'arrive pas à
lire et que termine par le temps
s'enfuit déjà tracé deux gardiens en
hauteur tu verras la grappe de raisin
peut-être en lien avec tes images qu'il
y a la sur le côté bon déjà on peut
décoder assez facilement le code quand
vous avez un code comme ça avec des
symboles il faut chercher en fait la
récurrence le e il est facile à trouver
c'est celui qu'on voit le plus donc là
c'est l'arbre donc on sait l'arbre c'est
le E du coup syllabes c'est le e il y a
de fortes chances que la petite feuille
ici ce soit a et que l'espèce de je sais
pas ce que c'est c'est peut-être un
tonneau ce serait un si c'est le cas ça
ferait simple ici on pourrait y accéder
à un haut pour le soleil donc rose line
Sainte-Roseline Sainte-Rose line bagnole
d'elle bizarre
apparemment c'est Roselyne bagnole
d'elle j'ai dit que ça c'était un a Maes
d'elmarès la croix c'est forcément oh du
coup la croix Saint-Georges teint clair
sur ça doit être un U ça sur l'aile tu
dis que ça c'était un U donc d'un
dunkerka Boston en Gaule en Gaule stade
Florent Florent Florentia
Florentia ok donc ce sont des lieux ça
c'est clairement des lieux peut-être à
tracer sur une carte sur une vraie carte
normale là quand on récupère comme ça
des lieux le premier réflexe ce serait
d'aller sur internet pour aller taper la
croix Saint-Georges voir ce que c'est
voir un petit peu c'est quoi ces lieux
si vraiment ce sont des lieux d'ailleurs
et puis après regardez un petit peu sur
les illustration par exemple sur la
première illustration et si on a une
espèce de carte d'Europe donc c'est
vraiment l'idée c'est d'essayer d'abord
moi c'est ce que je vous recommande vous
notez tout ce que vous arrivez à décoder
à comprendre toutes les hypothèses que
vous arrivez à faire vous les faites
dans un carnet c'est pas d'essayer de
résoudre de manière linéaire c'est
d'essayer d'aller choper des
informations un peu partout de tout
noter et après une fois qu'on a son
premier agglomération d'essayer de voir
comment on peut assembler des choses
ensemble mais je trouve ça canon de ne
pas avoir fait un livre mais une grande
carte au trésor ça tu as clairement
envie de l'afficher chez toi au dessus
d'une table avec des encyclopédie un
carnet de quoi noter de quoi réfléchir
la boîte elle est disponible à la FNAC
dans les boutiques de jeux de société
sur Amazon sur leur site bref je vous
mets tous les liens dans la description
vous ai pas fait voir non plus tous les
détails de toutes les énigmes parce que
sinon ce serait pas cool pour eux mais
je vous recommande de le faire cette
chasse au trésor elle a été lancée par
l'entreprise un seul avec le Petit Futé
comme partenaire officiel la cave de
100.000 euros sera exposée pendant toute
la durée du jeu à la vue de de la grande
cave du château de Vaux-le-Vicomte qui
se prête au jeu pour l'occasion quant à
la cave elle a été fournie par plus de
40 domaines viticoles un peu partout en
France elle comporte d'ailleurs des
crues exceptionnels comme les vins de
Louis XVI c'est incroyable du Château La
Bastide orliaques les vins de
Marie-Laure lutronc qui est membre de la
plus grande dynastie viticole du monde à
Bordeaux et elle a été également fournie
cette cave par la participation du
château villegeorges ou encore un
domaine pépite dans le Chinon avec
Pierre et Bertrand coulis et comme je
vous le disais quand j'ai déplié la
carte c'est un peu plus détaillé toute
la liste à jour en mars 2023 des
détaillés directement sur la grande
carte qu'on déplie et maintenant j'ai
plus qu'un truc à vous dire la chasse
est ouverte c'est à vous de jouer donc
je vous le répète vous allez bien dans
la description
en troisième chasse je vous parle de
Masquerade c'est troisième chose de
trésor c'est c'est une véritable enquête
policière c'est une chasse qui a captivé
l'Angleterre pendant quasiment trois ans
mais qui sait pas vraiment déroulé comme
elle devait se dérouler en 1976 il y a
une maison d'édition qui lance un défi à
kit Williams de faire quelque chose qui
n'a jamais été fait auparavant dans un
livre d'illustration pour enfants kit
William c'est un artiste très remarqué
pour ses peintures figuratives mais ce
défi lui semble un peu insurmontable et
refuse sauf que c'est trop tard la
graine elle s'est implantée dans son
esprit comme Inception et de la va
naître la plus grande chasse au trésor
que l'Angleterre est connu pendant trois
ans kit Williams va réaliser 15
peintures et écrire une histoire épique
pour compléter les peintures pour
compléter ses œuvres mais comme dans
toute chasse au trésor un peu surtout
qu'il y a un trésor dans l'histoire il
fallait retrouver un lièvre et quitte
Williams a alors décidé de créer un
bijou un pendentif pour être très précis
sous la forme d'un lièvre en or 18
carats estimé à 5000 livres le 7 août
1979 William enterre le trésor dans un
endroit qui tient secret évidemment
quelque part en Angleterre et qui se
trouve en réalité être dans le parc
d'antil 6 semaines plus tard le livre de
kit Williams contenant tous les indices
pour la localisation du bijou est
publiée la chasse au trésor est lancée
les chercheurs sont en ébullition et
tout le monde veut mettre la main sur le
butin c'est genre un phénomène de
société certains milieux représentés
dans les peintures de Williams sont
rapidement devenus des zones où les
chercheurs venaient creuser un peu trop
creusés des chercheurs il y en avait
beaucoup donc pour que l'Angleterre ne
se retrouve pas retourné par des pioches
et des pelles dans tous les sens
délocalisations ont vite été écartées
pour protéger certaines zones
délocalisations négatives c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle les zones qu'on écarte des
zones de recherche cette chasse a pris
une ampleur que kit Williams avait pas
vraiment prévu et de fait il avait pas
pris quelques précautions comme prendre
un pseudonyme pour pas qu'on connaisse
son nom et qu'on gagne le harceler je
vous laisse imaginer le nombre de
courriers qu'il a reçu de la part des
chercheurs parfois jusqu'à 100 LED par
jour sans compter tous les appels qui
recevaient directement chez lui il y a
une anglaise elle lui a même envoyé des
milliers de lettres avec une
localisation
dans chacune des lettres en espérant
juste tomber au pif sur la bonne zone
elle a fait comme les bottes vous savez
qu'il essaye de faire du forsball pour
casser un code heureusement en février
1982 quelques mois avant ma naissance
hazard je ne pense pas Williams reçoit
un courrier qui contient un dessin qui
indiquait précisément l'emplacement de
la cachette il appelle alors
l'expéditeur un certain Ken Thomas pour
lui annoncer qu'il est le grand gagnant
de la chasse au trésor il annonce alors
publiquement que le bijou a été localisé
Ken Thomas va déterrer le trésor et
c'est ainsi que Sun la fin de cette
chasse incroyable mais non en fait pas
du tout c'est pas fini loin de là le
problème c'est que Ken Thomas n'a jamais
su donner la solution exacte de l'énigme
explique qu'il est tombé sur ce résultat
un peu par hasard alors déjà là c'est
Bob c'est pas ouf chose étrange il
refuse de se montrer un visage découvert
et ne laisse apparaître aucun
enthousiasme dans sa découverte
d'ailleurs c'est tenant quand même pour
pour quelqu'un qui chasse depuis
plusieurs années il est pas heureux
d'avoir trouvé le trésor sans parler de
la déception aussi du créateur qui te
William ce qui a travaillé trois ans sur
une énigme que le gagnant n'a pas
vraiment résolu entièrement et qui
semble pas très heureux d'avoir trouvé
le trésor et c'est là que le Sunday
Times va décider d'enquêter de révéler
la partie sombre de cette histoire le
vrai nom de Kent Thomas c'est en réalité
de Galles Thompson qui avait pour
collègue John garde qui était lui-même
le petit ami de l'ex-compagne de kit
Williams
je le refais à l'envers quitte Williams
a une petite amie cette petite amie
quitte quitte Williams ça met un nouveau
petit ami qui s'appelle John garde John
garde un collègue qui s'appelle de
Galles Thompson et de galtomson se fait
passer pour kentumas comprenez un petit
peu donc en gros le gagnant avait eu la
possibilité d'obtenir des informations
précieuses peut-être pas toute la
solution grâce à l'ex petit ami de kit
Williams Véronica elle s'appelle comme
ça avait en effet eu connaissance de
l'emplacement approximatif elle savait
pas l'endroit précis de la cache au
trésor tout en ignorant par contre la
solution de l'énigme mais il y aura
quand même deux véritables gagnants les
deux seuls qui comptent pour kit
Williams à ses yeux il s'agit de deux
amis Mike Barker et John Russo qui avait
envoyé une lettre à William seulement
quelques jours après qu'il ait reçu la
première lettre du premier faux gagnant
on va dire les deux amis avaient donné
un détail de la résolution des énigmes
ainsi que la localisation précise du
Trésor a quand même une justice
commencer à quel point des personnes
peuvent s'impliquer dans une chasse au
trésor au point de sacrifier du temps en
famille et même de l'argent ça fait
plaisir
[Musique]
maintenant on part sur les traces de
l'ordre 6 une chasse au trésor qui a été
résolue pas plus tard que l'année
dernière donc c'est très très frais
c'est les éditions du Trésor qui avait
lancé cette chasse incroyable ça a été
un grand succès cette maison d'édition
peut-être vous le connaissez déjà pour
ceux qui me suivent depuis longtemps
c'est avec eux que j'avais créé ma
propre chasse au trésor l'impossible à
faire des diamants volés notamment grâce
à Julien Alvarez qui est un vrai
chasseur de trésors et qui est le
fondateur de la maison d'édition que
vous avez pu voir dans mon documentaire
sur la chute d'or tout ce boucle lors de
six panes a été lancé en 2021 à
l'univers est assez fou assez immersif
il a été conçu comme si c'était un récit
d'aventure donc on y suit la trace de
deux aventuriers à des époques
différentes avec adake la promesse d'une
statuette d'une valeur de 50 000 euros
pas mal honnêtement je trouve que ce
trésor et est très très beau il est
sublime c'est une statuette en or massif
aux yeux d'émeraude réalisé au Pérou par
un joyeux spécialiste dans la culture
précolombienne
Mochica moshica je crois que ça se dit
comme ça il y avait tous les éléments
d'une chasse au trésor comme on peut en
rêver une carte au trésor un carnet de
bord d'un mystérieux aventurier des
symboles des
en septembre 2022 soit un an et demi
après le début de la chasse très
rapidement les éditions du Trésor ont
donné la résolution complète des énigmes
afin de là aussi apporter des réponses
aux autres chasseurs qui soient pas
frustrés donc j'imagine quand même que
ça doit être un peu un peu rageant quand
on voit les résultats pour peu qu'on
soit pas si loin des bonnes réponses ou
juste à deux doigts d'avoir pu parvenir
ça doit mettre un peu les nerfs mais on
doit être content d'avoir la
satisfaction que ça terminé de pouvoir
comprendre les énigmes c'est un peu
comme d'avoir tu sais tous les chiffres
du Loto sauf un tu es là parlons des
trésors aussi des couverts par hasard
parce que il y a ça aussi c'est une
manière de chasser les trésors vous
pouvez juste être attentif ou que vous
alliez parce qu'on n'est jamais à l'abri
tomber sur un véritable trésor c'est
arrivé à plein de reprises et il y a des
histoires qu'on les ressorties d'un
espèce de conte fantastique au nord de
la Chine en 1974 un paysan et ses
employés décident de creuser un puits
pour arroser leur culture normal tout se
passe bien normal il creuse très
longtemps jusqu'au moment où il détérent
le coût d'une statue en terre cuite
normale il continue de creuser
découvrent donc une statue mais j'ai
l'impression de faire le vendeur pas des
statut pas sans statut à 1000 statuts
mais 8000 statues qui représentent des
soldats qui ont accompagné un empereur
du troisième siècle avant Jésus-Christ
mi soldat en circuit dans son champ ça
doit faire bizarre quand on n'est pas
prévenu de ça autre histoire en 2010 à
un homme qui rendait tranquillement dans
un bois jusqu'à ce qu'il voit un morceau
de tôle froissé sur le quiz dit ça doit
être un déchet qui a été laissé là un
peu par hasard jusqu'au moment où il va
voir il découvre 42 bijoux
principalement des parures en or qui
date du deuxième siècle avant
Jésus-Christ on parle de bijoux qui date
de plus de 2000 ans en vrai c'est fou ça
te refait un peu ta journée autre
histoire un ouvrier d'un immeuble à
Paris qui au moment de sa démolition
tombe sur 3000 pièces cachées dans un
mur parce qu'il va casser le mur avec un
papier qui indique qu'il s'agit d'un
héritage et là vous dites jackpot non
pas du tout il a cru que c'était des
pièces 7 sans valeur et les a donné à
son fils pour qu'il joue avec jusqu'au
jour ou un passant s'en aperçoit et
révèle au fils et donc au Père que ce
sont des pièces d'or donc il y avait
3000 pièces d'or et ça vaut de l'argent
c'est à dire un petit truc de 10
grandeurs c'est plusieurs centaines
d'euros déjà les chasseurs de trésors il
y en a eu depuis toujours en fait ce qui
est certain c'est que ça se démote pas
et encore moins depuis l'apparition du
géocaching le géocaching ça consiste à
chercher un trésor autour de vous très à
voir et pour ça vous avez juste besoin
d'un GPS le GPS de votre téléphone
portable par exemple ça suffit largement
ce sont des trésors sans valeur
monétaire c'est interdit des emporter
avec soit une fois qu'on les trouve
l'idée c'est pas de remporter un trésor
mais simplement de trouver la cache
c'est souvent un prétexte utilisé pour
visiter des régions ou des lieux que
pour faire des balades en famille tout
en faisant quelque chose de ludique de
très cool en 2017 le site geocaching à
répertorié je crois ces 3 millions de
cachettes dans le monde entier 3
millions la preuve que ça se démote pas
et qu'on aime toujours trouver la
cachette plus que le trésor même
peut-être il y a derrière des cachettes
qui sont très bien trouvées comme
celui-ci qui se trouve dans un tronc
d'arbre le procédé est vraiment malin
mais si vous voulez faire une vraie
chasse au trésor avec un vrai trésor à
la clé je vous rappelle que l'élixir
d'or n'attend que vous n'hésitez pas à
vous lancer si vous le sentez si vous
avez envie en famille avec vos amis pour
ma part moi j'aime bien partager ces
moments là avec des personnes qui ont le
même sens d'intérêt que moi pour
résoudre des énigmes parce que parce que
c'est cool à faire c'est comme un jeu de
société entre guillemets ça laisse des
bons souvenirs c'est le plus drôle c'est
ce que je préfère moi dans les chaises
trésor comme les xiiaires c'est pas le
trésor même si on aimerait l'avoir mais
c'est le chemin c'est tout ce qui se
construit autour donc pour cette chasse
qui est active là en ce moment tout est
dans la description pour vous procurer
donc le fameux parchemin qui contient
toutes les énigmes et dites moi en
commentaire qu'est-ce que vous préfériez
si vous vous trouvez le trésor est-ce
que vous vous garderiez le contenu de la
cave à vin ou est-ce que vous prendriez
directement le cash la valeur monétaire
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu à très
bientôt Ciao